I had an article that came through on a news group that I follow, and the article was called Boys Blind Cat with Laser Pen.
And this is in England.
And I guess there are four boys aged about twelve took turns to shine the laser into the cat's eyes.
And then it goes on to explain what they did.
But the uh part that I have highlighted here that I wanted to ask you about, and you apparently answered it already, but I just want to clarify it.
It says the poor cat was screaming and must have been in appalling pain.
The vet told me the backs of his eyes have been completely burned out.
Now, would that cause pain or when they say the retina is burnt, it's just burnt from the energy.
Um that type of pain.
I'm sort of at a loss to uh to to give you any direct uh or correct information there because I've never looked into that, but I can tell you that from a personal experience that uh when I was performing lasers at Expo eighty six in Vancouver, I was lining up a twenty watt laser in daylight, and uh my hand slipped on the mirror and the beam crossed my eye very briefly, and I did suffer a small burn in the uh peripheral vision area of the eye.
And while I didn't feel any pain immediately when it happened, I did have a headache and I did have blurry vision for several hours thereafter.
Yeah.
I was just curious because it was the laser pen that had done this.
I I have difficulty believing that because theoretically you'd have to fix the target object very, very s uh uh rigidly, and you'd have to fix the laser with a tripod or some other mount very rigidly.
If you've got a human holding it in their hand, no matter you can try this yourself if you have a laser pointer.
Point it at a wall about ten feet.
Oh, I know, you cannot hold the dot still.
It's really very difficult.
So yes, simply because just the actual movement of blood in your hands and your muscles and the natural trembles that occur in the muscles will cause that dot to dance around.
Yeah.
Because there's a lot of times you see the media loves loves to grab a hold of something, and I I just wasn't I'm I'm totally against any type of thing against the case.
But a few months back, the uh show American Journal, which is one of those uh tabloid TV shows, did a piece on uh the dangers of lasers in airspace, and they arranged to have a twenty watt laser set up outdoors, and they got a helicopter pilot to fly through it and and give his impressions and so on.
And what was rather interesting was that uh Patrick Murphy, the Gilda Aerospace Issues coordinator, was there, as well as uh Greg Makoff, who is the chair of the safety committee for the International Laser Display Association.
And uh they observed this and participated in it, and what they found very interesting was that first of all the uh pilots actually found the laser beam really amazing.
Once when they knew that they were going to be flying into it and they had been forewarned of what effects they could expect, they didn't have any difficulty with it.
They also thought it was a very cool thing, it would make a great device for using in a glide path to show people coming in where where the runway was.
Now, interestingly enough, American Journal focused on the most sensationalistic and negative aspects of the of the story, and in actual fact, uh in true tabloid style, the uh television shot that they showed of glaring blinding light that was impossible, almost impossible to see through, was actually from a xenon searchlight and not a laser.
Uh now, for those people who are interested in pursuing this, if you go to W W W dot Tangle and p-a-n-g-ol I N dot com, uh and you go to the American Journal TV page, you can download an MPEG file which has the entire show and there's also a detailed analysis of it there.
Okay.
And you also have a site which is a fantastic site for lasers.
Any information that anyone would want is on this site.
We want to tell uh the listeners a little bit about your site.
We'll have a link for that also.
Sure.
Laserfx.com is basically divided into two areas.
The front stage or public area is just is is uh aimed at the general public and it has information on how laser shows work, uh information for people doing laser science projects, and general information about the industry and some of the things that are going on, the newsletter, conference, etcetera.
Then we have the backstage area, which is open to the public if people care to uh go there.
And uh it is contains more detailed technical information.
There's uh our newsletter is available there, back issues of the newsletter are available there, uh technical information, technical papers, archives of standards information, uh a new section has been added recently called Pinouts, which lists the pin outs of some of the more popular uh uh boards that are used uh in laser displays.
And there's a resources directory there too for people looking for products and services in the industry.
Did you put the site together?
Mm-hmm.
My goodness.
There's about ten meg of material online to actually run it off our own server so that way we can do updates as things happen.
And uh it's a pretty uh big job.
Takes me uh a few hours every day just to keep up on everything that's going on there.
Well, I want to encourage our listeners to uh click on that link and go visit the page after they listen to the interview.
I did want to mention that the uh Laser FX ninety eight conference is not a closed conference.
There are only two laser industry conferences uh in the world each year.
This is Laser Light Show specifically.
One of them is the International Laser Display, which will be taking place in Amsterdam this fall, but you must be a member to attend.
Our conference is open to anyone.
Uh so people can come and just enjoy some really great laser shows.
Last year in the competition we had laser shows competing from uh Sweden, Germany, all over the United States, and Canada.
Uh the uh this year we have not only the special audience scanning workshop, but we also have uh Tim Walsh, who is an award-winning laserist from Texas who've created uh quite a lot of really great shows, who's going to be doing a special creative seminar and showing off some of his work in discussing the creative ideas behind it.
Let's take an imaginary person.
They've got a little bit of bankroll in the uh with savings account and they'd like to get started with laser light shows.
How would you recommend they proceed with that?
Well, the technology itself has actually become cheaper uh in the last few years, and uh a lot of people start off by being laser hobbyists, and it's no more expensive than any other hobby, say owning a motorcycle or uh a snowmobile.
Uh they buy themselves some equipment and start experimenting with lasers, and that can take the basis of uh starting with a very simple system that uses wobbling mirrors to make less-the two type patterns with information about that in the hobby zone in the backstage.
There are now a number of freeware and shareware laser graphics programs available for download from the net.
Oh, really?
Yes.
And uh there's uh the cost of scanning systems has dropped.
The the devices that we use, the galvanometers that we use for making lasered images, has dropped and the quality has gone up.
Cambridge Technology a number of years ago introduced Galvos that are now doing 30,000 points per second.
In three years the standard of the industry had been twelve thousand point per second galvos.
So now that you can take the older style open loop galvos and using the accelerator 124 technology, you can drive those at speeds high enough to make uh proper quality, reasonable quality graphics.
Uh in the old days a basic scanning system would have set you back somewhere in the neighborhood of two and a half to three thousand US dollars.
Now you can put one together for under a thousand US dollars.
And it's quite possible to spend less than two thousand US dollars and come up with a functional laser graphics system uh based on a hundred milliwatt uh air cooled argon laser suitable for uh doing basic light show type applications and graphics and animations.
Well that's that's amazing.
I think I I didn't think the costs were that low.
No, they've gone right down.
That's incredible.
The uh other uh development that has come along in in uh recent years has been the maturing of the white light laser.
Many years ago krypton lasers with all line optics were used to produce multiple colors and uh in the last few years a lot of research and effort has gone into creating white light lasers and there are even very compact units out now.
For example laser physics makes one that's only about twenty uh four inches long and puts out three hundred milliwatts of uh white light.
Coupling this with a PCAOM which is short for polychromatic acoustic optic modulator, you can now modulate multiple lines simultaneously in an inline device.
So in the old days we used to have to split the laser beam up and send it through different modulators and then recombine it, which was a very inefficient process and took a lot of parts and work to do.
Now we have a simple inline crystal that can just be popped in front of the laser beam, driven with an appropriate modulator, and it's possible to get 16.7 million colors out of a system that has eight-bit resolution.
And some laser graphic systems are now even controlling multiple lines, up to six lines, and are possible with doing trillions of colors.
So the quality of the images that you're seeing in laser shows has improved drastically with the introduction of the new scanning systems.
The color uh of the systems has improved with the introduction of uh uh photopically balanced white light lasers, and the color control of the image that you're seeing has improved.
And uh you're even starting to see now some rasterized images where people have created images made of lines because since you can control the color so subtly, you can get almost television like images out of a laser.
Obviously, this isn't you know full screen, full motion video, it's still an animated effect.
But uh nonetheless, the the advances in the technology have brought great artistic advances to the field, and uh particularly in uh audience scanning effects, which we were discussing earlier, the uh uh sheets of light and cones and so on that go through the audience now are no longer limited to the typical seven colors that you used to see, but can have lots of subtle shading and texture in them, and it makes it very beautiful to be bathed in a sea of lasers.
I understand that uh some of the laser light shows are actually just coming on a truck, leaving the truck outside and feeding the laser light into the facility using fiber optics.
That that technology has been around for a long time, and I don't know too many people who are doing that uh at the moment, but there are a couple of people who have trucks that are outfitted typically with higher power YAG lasers.
One of the nice things about the uh frequency double DA glazers is that they're very power efficient.
There's uh a system available that given a two twenty volt stove plug uh and a very minimal amount of water, I think it's about one gallon per minute at 20 PSI, will output 45 watts of green light.
So this is almost perfect for advertising because something like that could be cooled with a recirculator, which is a a tank radiator and fan assembl uh pump and fan radiator and fan assembly.
And uh the uh outdoor applications for that are uh really enormous because you can mount the thing in a cube fan, put in a small scanning system, and with a a very small generator and a small amount of water, you can be essentially a self-contained laser advertising vehicle.
As far as some of the newer patterns and things that we see when we go to laser light shows, what are some of the latest things that are being created?
A lot of work has gone into uh 3D graphics uh platforms that that allow people to create images by means of uh database 3D.
This is the same kind of 3D you see on television.
The image is flat, but the rotating logo is calculated in such a way that it appears to be three dimensional and it has perspective and occlusion and so on.
We're seeing a lot of developments in that area, and some very, very creative work from from people.
Lasers, uh projected laser images are a limited medium when you compare them to other mediums because the amount of information we can display is fairly small, even given the new scanner technology that we have, the amount of information we can display is in the neighborhood of uh fifteen to eighteen hundred points of of uh information compared to the thousands and thousands of pixels you have on a television or a computer screen.
But the difference, the the the advantages and disadvantages or the difference is that artistically lasers produce a much more three-dimensional image because of the very high contrast ratio between the image and the background, and also because uh of the very vibrant and vivid colors.
And there are also certain kinds of artistic effects that you can get with lasers that you just can't get any other way, and these are things like optical effects, lumias, and abstracts, which are the strength of the medium.
The early laserium shows were based entirely around that and made little or no use of graphics at all.
And now we have uh a lot of shows where there's a lot of representational stuff, or you go to a sports event and you get to see a lot of beams shooting around and players' names being written on the ice and that sort of thing.
Uh to in to me, I'm I guess sort of an old school laserist having been in the business now for almost twenty four years.
I really enjoy a good abstract show where I can just sit back and enjoy the abstract patterns and and effects which can be generated in no other way than laser.
Mm-hmm.
The other thing about laser beam effects and and audience scanning is uh typically when you do see these kinds of effects in uh nightclubs in the US anyway, they're all over your head, and there's no contact between the audience and the laser.
In other countries where uh international standards are followed and audience scanning is uh used, the laser actually reaches out and touches people.
And and you'll be amazed when you go to a rave in Canada and you see a ceiling of light being projected over the dances, how many people reach up and put their hands in it and play with it.
It's it's just sort of a natural impulse almost when people see this that they want to touch it and play with it.
And what's the what's the deal here in the US?
It it's difficult for me to say because I'm not you know really uh involved and I don't do shows in the United States because of the burden of paperwork.
But uh there are certainly legitimate safety concerns.
It is possible to damage people with uh damage people's vision with the audience scanning uh shows mm and I think that uh the United States has erred on the side of caution and perhaps gone a little overboard on it.
In terms of changing it, I think uh until we until you in the United States have a president or some other high official who really loves laser shows, nothing's really likely to happen although the international laser display people have been working with your regulators down there.
But bureaucracy is one of those things that's very difficult to change and uh you know sort of the attitude becomes well we've always done it this way, why should we do it any other way?
Are you still doing laser light shows on your own?
Oh yes.
Uh quite regularly in fact I'll be out this Friday doing one in a high school.
Oh okay great.
Uh I do a lot of high school dances, raves and parties.
I invented the laser dance party uh twenty three years ago and uh that is my favorite type of show to do the corporate shows.
I don't enjoy it quite as much because there you're often constrained in what you can do by what the client's requirements are, the amount of time they have and how many times they want to see their product logo or the information.
Whereas at a rave or a party you've got a six or eight hour time span in which you can spend a lot of time playing with a lot of different effects and I enjoy performing the laser live rather than sitting back and let the computer do the show for me.
Mm-hmm.
What are some of the bigger names in laser light shows?
Do we have a super group of laser light show people?
Top top three names, laser light show creators.
Well it's it doesn't it doesn't quite work that way because laserists are the invisible stars behind the scene.
In in other words if you go to a concert and you hear a great piece of music, you know the name of the guy who played it or wrote it or sang it.
Mm-hmm.
You go to a a a hockey game or a big sporting event or a Fourth of July or a Canada Day show and you see an amazing laser and fireworks spectacle, you don't know who did that.
Yeah.
Uh the person who spent hundreds of hours designing and choreographing the show, anime creating the animations for it, uh synchronizing and choreographing the fireworks with the lasers, is some guy out there on a scaffold back way back where the public doesn't see them, it's not like you get to step into the spotlight and bow.
There are exceptions to that.
I do uh a couple of tours each year in which I'm actually a featured performer as part of a variety show.
Mm-hmm and I get to take a bow.
But most of the time we're anonymous uh as laserists and we have to sort of get our enjoyment from performing and our feedback from hearing the crowds roar and cheer and whistle at a distance.
In terms of what companies are the most well known, obviously the most famous company is the one that started it all, uh which is Laserium out of California.
And uh then following uh on that, the two companies that are most active in producing a lot of planetarium shows at the moment are Audiovisual Imagineering in Florida and Laser Fantasy, which are located in the Seattle area.
So those are sort of the companies that a lot of people see.
But the industry has been changing many years ago because of the cost of the technology and you know the support that was needed for it and when you went on tour you virtually had to take double everything because something was bound to break.
Uh big laser companies with dozens of employees and hundreds of uh uh uh jobs all the time were the uh rule and in fact a lot of these companies were structured where they had artists and animators who never left the shop and who simply animated and created shows in the shop and then they had other performing laserists who went out with the equipment and did shows.
But that has changed quite significantly in the last ten years and now we're entering the age of the m small and medium sized company and even the one person operation uh the technology has become more reliable it's become more uh flexible as to what you can do simpler and easier to use higher quality uh output and cost less so now it's possible for a one person operation to uh to serve a significant market but as it says in chapter two of Laser FX the Light Show Handbook can you make can you get rich doing laser shows?
And the answer is no.
Nobody in this business has really got spectacularly rich and I tend to think that's because laserists are the starving artists of the nineties.
Mm-hmm just as artists starved in freezing garrets in France for their for their art.
Laserists work very long hours under arduous conditions with a lot of technical difficulties and most of us do it not because we want to get rich, but because we enjoy the art form and we enjoy working with lasers.
You mentioned your book.
Do you want to tell us a little about the book?
Um yeah, uh I I attend a lot of conferences and uh I'm one of the people who believes that everything should be open and people uh should tell each other about how things are done.
Uh when the industry first started and I first got into it many years ago everything was proprietary in a trade secret.
Nobody would tell you how it was done.
And it took me months and months and months of research to figure out how to do the simplest thing which is a Lumia effect.
You take a piece of bumpy glass or plastic, hold it in a laser beam and rotate it slowly and it makes these lovely walking gas cloud type of effect.
Well nobody wanted to tell me how that was done.
So I decided to start telling people about how things were done.
So anybody who called me or talked to me I would give them that information.
But it got to be a burden after a while and I found I was answering the same questions over and over and I think this was in the days before the World Wide Web and FAQs became a big thing.
So I decided to sit down and write a book about it.
So I spent two years writing a four hundred and some odd page book which is the only detailed technical manual on laser light shows available in the industry.
The Bible I've heard it called that's what I've heard it called I don't call it that myself.
And so far the uh it's uh published in small uh runs and uh made available through our website and through people who come to the laser conferences or who call us and I sold copies to people as far away as uh Russia, Korea, Japan, uh Hong Kong, uh China, uh Australia, New Zealand, all over North America, South America, Chile.
So it's uh it's done uh quite well considering that it's not being backed by a major publisher and there's about uh three or four hundred copies in circulation now.
Great, great well I think we probably should call it quits.
Have we filled our time slot?
We're uh we're approaching twenty six megs on the audio file so well you're gonna have to do some cutting and hacking there.
Yeah I don't usually take too much out of a show though.
Okay.
It's been it's been an honor speaking with you.
I thank you myself and the whole talk listeners for coming on.
We're basically holography related but we touch on the lasers and laser light shows a new area probably for a lot of people that listen to this show, but I bet you there's a lot of people out there doing holograms that think, I bet you I could take this laser and do a laser light show with it.
Uh-huh yeah that's true.
Well thanks very much for having me on and uh look forward to uh doing this again sometime in the future.
Okay thank you very much.
Right.
Bye bye